foreign
[Music]
we can see how technologically advanced
these people really were
[Applause]
it shocks modern archaeologists because
they don't know how it's done
[Music]
hey guys what was the world like before
the flood also known as the
anti-diluvian period
what I'm going to describe to you in
this video is going to blow you away
because it's going to sound like almost
like a fantasy world only that it was
real
and so we're going to look at the Bible
other ancient writings and also
archeology are you ready for this
let's start with the people first in the
time before the flood
Genesis 5 3-5 when Adam had lived 130
years he fathered a son in his own
likeness after his image and named him
Seth
the days of Adam after he fathered Seth
were Aid 100 years and he had other Sons
and Daughters thus all the days that
Adam lived were 930 years and he died so
the first thing we realized is that
people got old they lived hundreds of
years it's not like today
think about what this means
if you lived at that time
you could have known your great great
great great great
Granddad so most of the grandchildren at
that time probably heard the creation
stories from Adam and Eve directly first
hand
methusole who is Noah's grandfather
lived to be the oldest man that we know
about and he was 969 years old now a lot
of people say well that can't be true we
can't believe that the scale was
probably different 100 years for them
was probably 10 years
well they don't think further than that
what it actually means what they are
saying because mahalal and Enoch
followed their first Sons at 65 and at
70 years old so think about it if 100
years represents 10 years these guys
would have been six and seven years old
father at six and seven I don't think so
remember when God created Adam he said
that he was good perfect right that was
before sin came into the world also Eve
they were perfect DNA perfect perfect
human beings your great great great
great grandparents were perfect
and they could have lived in the Garden
of Eden for many years maybe even 100
years because remember they only got
Seth when Adam was 130 years old
but when sin came into the world
everything changed imperfections came
into the DNA of humankind especially if
you look at thousands of years we die
earlier we're not getting better like
evolutionists say we're getting worse
we're dying much earlier Ken Ham
explains it very well in the new answer
book
when the first two people were created
they were perfect everything God made
was very good Genesis 1 verse 31 that
means their genes were perfect no
mistakes but when sin entered the world
because of Adam in Genesis 3 6 God
cursed the world so that the perfect
creation then began to degenerate that
is suffer death and Decay Romans 8 22.
over a long period of time this
degeneration would have resulted in all
sorts of mistakes occurring in the
genetic material of living things
now also remember because the DNA was so
good right and because they had to
multiply on the earth remember it says
that Adam and Eve they had Seth and then
many other children right so that's
where Cain found his wife
at that time brothers and sisters they
married because the DNA was perfect
there's no imperfections that would only
happen 2500 years later
which is a long time for imperfections
to creep in and then God gave the
command to Moses and says for the nation
of Israel brothers and sisters cannot
marry each other now let's just go back
to the time before the flood the people
at this time who were perfect were
strong men and women lived for many
hundreds of years they lived in a brutal
evil World there were a lot more animals
today there are a lot of animals that
are extinct back then lions
yeah
Bears
dragons in the Bible
a world of of wickedness when the
Nephilim came the Mighty Men of old the
Giants also and certain translations the
Bible says that Fallen Angels Came Down
demons slept with the woman on earth and
they brought forth the Nephilim mixed
breeds between humans
and Fallen Angels you had to be a strong
human being to survive in this world
this was an extremely evil world
men became more wicked over time as well
that's why Genesis 6 5 says the Lord saw
that the wickedness of man was great in
the earth and that every intention of
the thought of his heart was only evil
continually so imagine living in this
evil brutal harsh World being
a Godly Man wanting to worship God
living righteously you had to probably
build safe camps for you and your family
and over time especially if you lived
hundreds of years you would have
probably started your own tribe or Clan
and imagine all the knowledge that you
would gain over hundreds of years I mean
people today when there are 50 60 70
years old I like to listen to them
because they have a lot of experience
and they gained a lot of knowledge
imagine people who are 700 800 900 years
old
we see this with Cain how he started
whole cities Genesis 4 16 then Cain went
away from the presence of the Lord and
settled in the Land of Nod East of Eden
Cain knew his wife and she conceived and
bore Enoch
when he built a city he called the name
of the city after the name of his son
Enoch well he built his own City imagine
that
now the Bible only describes the
lineages the family trees of only the
firstborns right the males but it
doesn't explain all the other people
that could have lived at that time I
believe there were a lot more people
than people today think there were
imagine how many kids you could have had
in 900 years according to the Guinness
Book of Records the greatest officially
recorded number of children born to one
mother is 69.
to the wife of Theodore vesalev between
1707 and 1782.
a peasant from shuya Russia in 27
confinements she gave birth to 16 pairs
of twins seven sets of triplets and four
sets of quadruplets now again imagine
how many kids you could get if you were
a perfect
female at that time right because they
were not a lot of imperfections yet and
if you live 900 years oh my goodness you
could have had a lot of kids to start a
whole tribe Clan this whole city by
yourself
that's exactly what Kane did and we also
see that from his other children as well
and we can see how technologically
advanced these people really were
Genesis 4 17 K knew his wife and she
conceived and bore Enoch when he built a
city he called the name of the city
after the name of his son Enoch to Enoch
was born Iraq and irat fathered mahuya
and muhial fathered matusha a matushao
fathered lamack and laymak took two
wives the name of the one was Ada and
the name of the other Zilla so this
shows us that one man could have had a
lot of children because a lot of them
could have had more than one wife verse
20 Ada bore jabal he was the father of
those who dwell in tense and have
livestock so they weren't dumb they
didn't live just in caves and were like
ape men not only do evolutionists lie
about this they've lied about many other
things as well but they never come out
with the truth and said oh we lied about
this it only happens when they are
caught like the well-known pulled down
man they found Ukrainian belong to a
modern human and a Jawbone belonged to
an orange utum or a chimpanzee it was
all deceivingly put together to look old
and to match they even filed down the
teeth and then we have the Nebraska man
it was named in 1922 from a human-like
tooth found in Nebraska they used one
tooth to build an entire species of
primitive man fully complete with even
his family
further excavations revealed that the
tooth actually belonged to a pet Curry
which is a type of pig no God says that
he created you if you were a ape man or
you come from Evolution then you have no
purpose you have no meaning and your
life means absolutely nothing you just
live like this amount of time here on
Earth and this short temporary world and
you die
and that's it
but Genesis 1 verse 27 says so God
created man in his own image in the
image of God he created him male and
female he created them so evolutionists
say that you are
here by chance right because a bunch of
chemicals mixed together basically a
piece of dirt and from this piece of
dirt slowly over millions of years
evolved in an ape and a better ape man
and voila a human after millions of
years
but God says I created you in my image
he loves us he's got a purpose for us
we are not just some mistake
you know
when uh demons see that humans are
falling for the lies
of evolution they probably think man
this is so funny we didn't think they
would even fall for their stupid lie wow
Lucifer you're so great father of Lies
wow it actually worked you know Hitler
said
if you tell a big enough lie until it
frequently enough it will be believed
all right well let me stop just going to
this direction and let's move back to
Cain's family we stopped at lamech verse
19 and lamech took two wives the name of
the one was Ada and the name of the
other Zilla Ada board jabal he was the
father of those who dwell in tents and
have livestock his brother's name was
Jubal he was the father of all those who
play the liar and pipe
so they weren't dumb they didn't
struggle to create tools they even
created tools had the time apart from
just tools for survival they had the
time to create tools for music to enjoy
music like The layering pipe verse 22
Zilla also bore two Volcan he was the
forger of all instruments of bronze and
iron the sister of tubal Kane was nama
all right so it's pretty straightforward
they weren't just cavemen they're just
stuck with rocks and just wood to create
their tools they knew how to forge
instruments with iron and bronze I do
not believe that we are getting smarter
like the evolutionists say I think we're
getting Dumber we're just building from
what the previous generation store us I
mean Adam walked with God in the garden
for a long time
he even named all the animals in one day
how much do you think God could have
taught Adam and Eve all that time that
they've spent in the garden
a lot and how much do you think that
Adam and Eve could have told their kids
their grand kids their great
grandchildren because think about this
the flood happened with Noah right but
Noah's father was still alive when Adam
was still alive he was 65 years old
excuse me no no not 65 56 years old so
Noah could have learned that from his
people there his parents his
grandparents his aunts he's I mean from
everyone and then after the flood he
taught the same things to his children
Genesis 9 verse 28 After the flood Noah
left 350 years all the days of Noah were
950 years and he died so if we look at
the population of the world at that time
you have Cain who went East right and he
started a whole city and his children
and they started hold plans and a lot of
the people probably spread in that area
and I believe a lot of them were
probably evil lamech probably the worst
of them all in verse 23 we read limex
said to his wives Ada and Zillah hear my
voice you wives of lamech listen to what
I say I have killed a man for wounding
me
a young man for striking me if Kane's
revenge is Sevenfold then lamex is
77-fold
so not only did he try to say that he
was worse than Cain who killed his
brother he wanted to boast about the man
that he's killing I mean it's just oh
man it's just evil but when we look at
the other side when we look at Adam and
Eve's other children after Seth we say
that a lot of them chose to worship God
especially in the time of enosh verse 25
and Adam knew his wife again and she
bore a son and called his name Seth for
she said God has appointed for me
another Offspring instead of Abel for
Cain killed him
Joseph also a son was born and he called
his name enosh at that time people began
to call upon the name of the Lord
so here you have different groups of
people you have a lot of people who
choose to live in sin like lamac some of
Cain's descendants and then you have
people who truly wanted to worship God
some of Seth's descendants
so you have all these people and they
spread throughout the world over time
started Clan cities and so you have this
whole population over the world and we
see evidence of it even today this is
what Josephus wrote Cain only cared
about gaining material things and
pleasing his flesh his wife is called
themek Cain was 15 years old when he
killed Abel and began to build cities he
created Seven Cities in total the name
of the first city according to the name
of his son Enoch the name of the second
City maoli then Leaf says
and the seventh the buff
I'm not saying 100 that these other
writings are accurate but it is
interesting and they are very old so a
lot of it could have been true
especially this now let's take a look at
archeology just a little bit to make
things interesting archeology that we
found today from the pre-flood world
it's a lot of people that are trying to
hide this number one the Black Sea
settlement 12 miles off the coast of
turkey Dr Robert D Ballard the same
person who discovered the Titanic found
this civilization 300 feet under the
surface
he found artifacts Stone implements and
carved beams and so forth I I mean
there's a lot I don't have a lot of time
to go into this in detail let's move on
to the second one
of the oldest and most mysterious cities
dating back to pre-flood times this is a
massive piece of architecture older than
any other man-made structure found
anywhere some even said it's the Garden
of Eden build a 43 maybe more different
megaliths huge pillars over 16 feet
that's around 5 meters tall
you know some of these ancient
structures we even with our best
technology today can't replicate it
because it was built with such Precision
I believe most of these big monoliths
you know these big Builders and stuff
were moved around by the Nephilim the
Giants of old let me just share a little
bit more on this go black itsepe was
found in modern day Turkey they found
these massive circular structures with
these huge pillars these pillars weigh 7
to 10 tons and is around 18 feet high
that is around five meters some stacked
one on another
so just think a little bit for yourself
how in the world did they create these
colors how did I move them all the way
here and how did they build it I mean
it's just insane carbon dating says that
it's it's older than 12 000 years I
believe more than six and here's a very
interesting thing they also found
drawings on it of animals
carved in the stone and in 3D
this all in a period where Evolution
tells us there might have only been cave
paintings that's the most advanced it
was supposed to be this art has been
done in extreme detail with images of
human beings and probably even Nephilim
faces on top of pillars let me ask you
where else have you seen this type of
Art 3D art faces on top of bodies
think about Egypt the Sphinx a lot of
people including myself believe that it
was built before the time period of the
flood
we cannot sensibly accept the insistence
of egyptologists that the Sphinx is just
four and a half thousand years old in
the 90s the rebuttal to any evidence
suggesting otherwise was always if it
was built by a civilization or a culture
that much earlier where is the other
evidence of this culture shown that many
archaeological site that dates to this
period Well that got blown out of the
water completely by the discovery of
gobekti Tepe located in Turkey Gobekli
tapi was discovered by accident when a
Shepherd stumbled over a bunch of these
old looking Stones sticking out of the
ground of this Hillside for many years
it was assumed to be nothing more than a
medieval cemetery and it wasn't until
1994 when German archaeologist Claus
Schmidt began studying the site that a
lot of other scientists started to take
you more seriously because once they
started Excavating site it was found to
contain large circular structures
supported by Massive Stone pillars each
weighing 7 to 10 tons sanding 18 feet
high with many of these Stones stacked
on top of each other and most
mysteriously of all it seems to have all
been deliberately buried in the ground
all at once as if to preserve it or hide
it altogether and due to carbon dating
of materials at the site modern
scientists have irrefutably dated it
back to around 12 000 years ago meaning
this site predates ancient Sumeria the
invention of writing and Stonehenge by
more than 6 000 years to put that into
perspective there was about as much time
between the construction of Gobekli Tepe
and the construction of Stonehenge as
there was between the construction of
Stonehenge and today making Gobekli Tepe
the oldest known megalithic site in the
world an eerie fact when you consider
where else you've seen the dichotomy of
an animal body with a human head eleven
thousand six hundred years old a giant
megalithic site my goodness if you can
make go back to Tempe you can make the
Sphinx
now remember I've just read to you how
Kane Winton created his own city named
after his own son a lot of the people
created whole towns and cities if you
can make
a beautiful amazing place like oblique
tepa before the time period of the flood
you can create a lot of others as well
the the time period here all lines up
this site has become the Smoking Gun
evidence that the Sphinx likely is much
older than we've been led to believe in
the dates when both of these sites were
likely created lines up perfectly with
the end of the last ice age that is the
date where it starts at Quebec and
precisely today Plato gives for the
destruction of Atlantis so if Plato made
it up it's really weird that he picked a
day that precisely coincides with the
latest geological evidence on
cataclysmic sea level rise at the end of
the Ice Age
the evolutionists just believed that it
was a time period of the Ice Age well we
know that the sea level Rose at that
time not because of an ice age but
because of the flood now also if you
look at the body of these things the
weather damage is not signs of wind and
sand but of water
so there's a lot of questions I mean if
you go into this Rabbit Hole you will
never stop because you would think okay
but how in the world did water get there
all the way in the desert well because
there was a flood and Before the Flood
that area was totally different the
world changed After the flood anyway we
need to move on the Indus they began
building settlements in present-day
India and Pakistan as early as 8 000
years ago according to archaeologists
making them one of the earliest
civilizations in North America the
chatata wall
on Huber Farm in Cleveland the farmer
found a pre-flood thick wall three times
longer than a football field they found
indecipherable inscriptions on it but no
one knows what it says
they don't know because that language
does not exist anymore it's from the
pre-flood period South America tiwanaku
many people say this was the spiritual
center of the Andes and the old
structures still remain Lake Titicaca is
also close by the Puma punku ruins are
built impressively with perfect Stone
fitting so that even paper can't fit
through it shocks modern archaeologists
because they don't know how it's done
then there's also the Gateway of the Sun
the Indian legend says the god viracocca
Rose from the Lake Titicaca after a
flood to help civilization on its feet
again
Japan the yonaguni monument found
underwater by a scuba diver and it's
over 180 by 150 feet no one knows who
built it and the government of Japan is
unfortunately not even looking into it
China Rock paintings found on the ginger
River this is in China's Yunnan province
in the southwest and dated to more than
13 000 years ago according to them more
than 70 rock paintings were discovered
in this area
Northwest Arabia cattle Cults according
to Armstrong institute.org they found
Monumental rectangular stone structures
or mustatels Arabic for rectangles
scattered throughout Northwest Arabia as
part of a prehistoric cattle cult
according to them the stone structures
all of which were dated to the sixth
millennium BCE were characterized as the
first large-scale Monumental ritual
landscape anywhere in the world and the
earliest evidence for cattle called in
the Arabian Peninsula along with cattle
related remains and rock art everyone
showed that the mustados were more than
merely cattle pens they were also used
in ritualistic activity now this sounds
familiar doesn't it we've just read it a
while ago Genesis 4 verse 19 and lamech
took two wives the name of the one was
ARA and the name of the other Zilla Ada
board jabal he was the father of those
who dwell in tense and have livestock
now I'm not saying that this is exactly
jabal's cattle call that they found I'm
just saying that they found evidence of
it the time period matches up and the
Bible also talks about it so it confirms
what the Bible says that there were
people who had cattle
now
let's focus a little bit in on
the world at that time the world power
in a sense the world governed if I can
call it that government was probably
handed down from Adam to Seth and they
ruled part of their area of the world
according to Josephus now of course we
don't know if this is really true but it
could have been
the Bible doesn't write anything about
this but Josephus does
of course Adam had many children they
respected him they knew he's our great
great great grandfather everybody knew
he was the first human being and he
probably taught them a lot of things
including that they should worship God
But as time went on people became more
evil
I mean at the end that's why God
destroyed the world in the time of the
flood because people only thought Evil
all the time
so imagine some of Adam's descendants
there living trying to keep the peace
trying to be righteous men and women of
God and the world is becoming evil so
they could have probably be some of the
peacekeepers trying to keep the peace
and just stand for truth especially in
their territory while you look at all
these other territories these people
becoming more evil and Evil half-breeds
coming in I mean demons are just evil
so now they come down they sleep with
the women of Earth and then you have
these half breeds
that we know from other ancient writings
that were very evil and the people
becoming more evil as well just like
lamech so people started to rebel
against God some of them also even
worshiped these demons and these
Nephilim as gods and it became so evil
that this happened Genesis 6 9 Noah was
a righteous man blameless in his
generation Noah walked with God and Noah
had three sons
now the Earth was corrupt in God's sight
and the Earth was filled with violence
and God saw the Earth and behold it was
corrupt for All Flesh had corrupted
their way on the earth and God said to
Noah I have determined to make an End of
All Flesh for the Earth is filled with
violence through them behold I will
destroy them with the Earth make
yourself an ark of gopher wood for
behold I will bring a flood of waters
upon the Earth To Destroy All Flesh in
which is the Breath of Life under Heaven
everything that is on the Earth shall
die but I will establish my Covenant
with you and you shall come into the ark
you your sons your wife and your son's
wives with you and of every living thing
of All Flesh you shall bring two of
every sword into the ark to keep them
alive with you they shall be male and
female of the birds according to their
kinds and of the animals according to
their kinds of every creeping thing of
the ground according to its kind two of
every sword shall come into you to keep
them alive also take with you every sort
of food that is eaten and store it up it
shall serve as food for you and for them
Noah did this he did all that God
commanded him now is evolution right
that all the animals just get here on
Earth because they evolved over time and
we as well or is it because the ark is
it because of Noah that he was obedient
to God and that we all can call him
greater great great granddad
the animals
that live here today is that from the
ark or is that from evolution
if it's from the ark is it possible to
bring all those animals on the ark and
what about the dinosaurs I mean there's
a lot of questions you guys probably
have and I will answer it in the next
video make sure you don't miss it and if
you haven't subscribed make sure you do
so now
thank you for the support guys I will
see in the next video and always
remember life is short so don't waste
yours cheers thank you